hello retech nation i'm greg who are you
i'm cat alvarado she's back on the
channel what it's me
halloween season you gotta have cat here
to check out some scary stuff
we're gonna watch nukes top five today
five scary ghost videos you shouldn't
watch in the dark
speaking of spooky and scary cat
alvarado has a podcast that i've been on
a couple of times
jamie kennedy's been on it that's right
she's trying to book
um ellen degeneres she's not
christie elliott all the caveaters right
now
you know what gotta take them while the
price is low
it's called villains of history we talk
about villains like robes pierre
and uh the rwandan genocide guy whoever
that was
oh you're plugging specific ones here
today we've got some crazy people
on the pod like okay they're not on the
podca we talk about them but we have
comedians
on the podcast making fun of the bad
guys
it's a good time no alcohol required
villains of history
transitioning to the reaction now
she said protein you guys missed that
protein is what she said protein
the hand is quicker than the eye
gareth williams says that he was doing
work on the cctv system
at the parking center for his local air
center harris says that while working
there
he often found his tools unexplainably
moved from one place to another
new workers at the parking center
claimed that the registers would
sometimes start spewing out tickets
in the middle of the night for no reason
it's the russians
what
a pale little hand seems to literally
come right out of the wooden edge of the
desk
and push an apple off onto the floor
workers didn't even notice until they
watched the cctv footage
back later
but there wasn't an apple there
something at the door what were they
saying about face-offs
[Laughter]
hanging lights will start to move back
and forth for no reason
earthquake doesn't object move from one
place to another
because they move them give it a second
is there someone on the other side you
you gotta give confirmation
i see yeah there could obviously be
someone on the other side you gotta keep
confirmation
was dark turn on the light
now when the video is slowed down you
can see
there are no cuts or edits in the
recording but it's
so dark in there it caused this bizarre
phenomenon
yeah it's too dark it's too dark
you can't fool me in one of my previous
videos
because he's a member of the popular
ghost hunting team walkie tally
jesus oh yeah because it can't break
through
strings happy spiritual type of string
in this video assad khan is
investigating a remote location that is
said to have been the site of many dark
occult rituals
also something from counter-strike
the main entrance is locked but they
begin to hear loud bangs on the doors
all around them
[Applause]
there's some short doors by the way
that's true assad and his cameraman
noticed that the main entrance seems to
randomly move
as they investigate yeah
okay
[Applause]
all right this could be planned though
right you could have people behind the
door 100 previously locked door just
pops open right decides to check inside
and it didn't go well
this is assad's death video
i could play assad in this biopic
totally look at the hair just straighten
yours and
[Music]
okay what do we see
what's the circle circling
yo this is your horror vlog channel you
got to commit man
oh i see it i see it i see it i see it
it had like a i was like
dude i didn't see anything this time
did it kick him in the
the videos
assad claims that something inside
grabbed his arm and hit him in the back
but yet he still goes back again to
investigate the room
okay he's kind of staying there dude
[Music]
did you see the clown clown vibes not
really
no okay but you know i just projected
that onto it
everything's open to interpretation
or is it all just an elaborate hoax
it looks like he's like about to break
dance like he's like yeah
he was recently doing some maintenance
what i see
he pulled out his phone and captured
this
oh schools at night are creepy
[Music]
that is not added now the sound has most
reddit commenters stumped
some have guessed that the noise could
be anything from the wind blowing under
doors
to noisy pipes yes but no one knows for
sure
it's too easy to add that all of the
comments seem to agree on
is that the unexplained noise in the
empty school
might not be over
[Music]
that audio sounds too clean yes bingo
not much is known about this next video
after extensive researching the only
info that i could come up with is that
the video is said to be from a security
camera in a hospital waiting room in
peru
oh
what are we looking at
is
is that in someone's spine what are we
looking at
here's the chairs in the waiting room
who's your chair there was a spine
okay
i thought it was like an exam room thing
continues into the hospital waiting room
and then just sort of disappears behind
the chairs
it could be a rat now perhaps the most
compelling part of this is
creepy watching the cctv seems to be a
die-hard non-believer
she just keeps repeating it's a person
[Music]
you said waiting room i thought you said
exactly
very old and obviously potato quality
but potato quality does this look like a
person
to you no let me know what you think not
with that potato
but that's such a weird footage because
like what was that so after so many
numbers
closely examining ghost videos i'd kind
of like to think that i have a pretty
good eye for spotting anything
potentially paranormal
in a video but sometimes viewers are
watching
even closer than i am twitter user the
jester 220 spotted this creepy little
bit that i missed in a featured franco
tv video
from over eight months ago what
bonus oh i think i saw this video
hello yeah i think i saw this one
so did you see it no
well i certainly didn't back then but
watch the corner
as frank pence's camera which corner
what someone or something
is peeking around the corner at frank
and ducks back
just as he turned it's so quick
and i'm amazed that anyone even noticed
it but the jester 220
did now this next clip was not actually
in my video but it was in a spooky video
that i featured from the channel tfil
over five months ago in the original
video
tfil are investigating the supposedly
haunted yorktown memorial hospital you
guys look like your
characters who get killed off in a
slasher movie
she dies first yeah did you hear that is
that moving
oh that that ball and her foot
[Music]
but twitter user kitty oof noticed
something that even the tfil crew
didn't see in one of the shots in the
original tfil video
the crew accidentally catches something
down the hall behind them
hello i want to hang out with these guys
did you see it what looks to be a dark
shadowy figure
seems to be floating down the hall
[Music]
even most of their viewers didn't notice
what
oh wow you
by the way before i go i wanted to point
out one other odd thing in the video
where a hand seems to push an apple
off a desk now i just have no
idea what these two guys are talking
about
something about chewing a face off
i guess oh
hey man that was good that was good
there's some good ones in here
there are the one with the door handle
come on obviously we know how we feel
about that i still think you could have
a hidden cut here and it's so dark
someone could easily be hiding
the first one though i'm more curious to
know what the hell they were talking
about
is that even an expression of words like
is that an idiom
of metaphor is that like because it can
sound like the one guy is
saying oh we got a crazy guy but then
the dude behind the counter is repeating
it back to him as if it's like some
bar talk they have you know face off
yeah chewing face off i don't know how
it is man just be chewing my face off
feeling off my face just like switching
my face with other people's faces you
know what i mean
this thing with the apple and this
little girl or hand or something
cat look there's no way you can explain
that well at first i thought it was an
optical illusion like i thought that
that's actually like a dresser
or or a like a refrigerator and the hand
is just popping out from behind it but
it's not because it's
how would that make more sense right
[Laughter]
it's not it's just what i thought that
it was and then it wasn't that
um it wasn't that you know it's not
there's a refrigerator there there's a
hand pump now it's like it's coming from
behind it like that
what that would be
creepy i have no explanation there's a
hand behind that fridge and it's moving
you lose
at first um like there could be people
around who are slamming the doors for
him
choreographed okay um but then there's
that little
uh clown doing hip-hop moves in the
distance
in the dark
what
it's a funny explanation it's funny all
right i mean they hired clowns far away
that's why he could only step in for 0.5
seconds or else people are going to know
it's
it's a paid clown he's acting he's like
clowns he runs away this stuff is called
the sod con
horror vlogs i'm more likely to believe
the videos that are
oh we stumbled across this and we didn't
even intend to capture something scary
yeah that emotion but when uh it's a
channel that's dedicated to like trying
to get
horror stuff hey was kind of letting me
down because
you are you just fanta by me every one
of my words right now
i'm pen and tolerant i'm letting you
know i'm invested in your conversation
the conversation forever
reflect what they're saying say they
know you're listening when he's going
into the
into the room and he's not even like
committing to staying in there
i'm thinking many thoughts one is you're
a horror vlog channel you should be just
going in there willy-nilly you're trying
to capture it don't you just want
something to rip your arm off
yeah so you get more views man
he's just like keeps going dipping in
and out it works for like a creep effect
it works for to get this little snippet
effect so they can play it back later
and really blow something up
and you know you know as cat interprets
it as like a creepy dancing pop clown or
something
it was kind of a letdown in that
department of just oh man i wish you
were just committing to going in there
because this now
now i'm more likely to believe you're
just faking this whole bit now yeah and
it's too easy with editing to fake
things
i mean you've seen the zack king stuff
and everything that like literally
anyone can do on tick tock this could
easily be like layering effect of like
oh we've got this video of a creepy
dancing clown let's make it blurry and
opaque yeah see
disprove to the tomb
you're done for assad sorry
sorry son you're losing subscribers as
we speak
this one in the school i agree
at night schools are terrifying i don't
know
what it is about it right i agree
yeah i have uh once or twice not like
for a pt meeting or something before
you know they were broken when you sneak
onto campus yeah you know
i was rehearsing for a play and we were
there till later
always trying to sell your acting career
just so i'm here
to be a human being once in a while but
yeah
one time i was auditioning i was a tree
okay
it wasn't a real play we all start
somewhere but it has the truth there's
no small parts just small actors
and it was a tree it was a big tree it
was a sequoia
you remembered didn't you that was that
that's a true statement
i still know the lines which were not
this school setting and the sound is too
crisp it has it's just obvious that he
got that from like some kind of stock
audio and then yeah that's editing for
you
[Laughter]
that's what it does in prologics
[Laughter]
the right one logic bro
uh final sounds
when you're listening to the audio it
the rest of the room tone
sounds a little muffled but then the
audio there
sounds like an insert so room tone
that's
that's he knows things he's showing off
you know yeah stuff
not like all the editing programs you're
listing right now
it would be muffled it would be muffled
if it was real yeah i'm glad we're
dedicating so much every conversation
let me explain to you the difference
between clean sound and not clean sound
i got to explain what was going on my
reaction on this one i said what are we
looking at
i thought cat said exam room so this
whole time
until you point out they were chairs i
thought we were looking at a spinal cord
oh yeah because there's going to be a
ghost on a spine that's always like
tripping me out i'm like
wait are they saying there's like a a
paranormal being living in this guy's
spine right now that would be his soul
ground because i thought
like these numbers had something to do
with the chart and whatever
so i was way confused on everything and
i and i was more baffled by how come
you're not reacting to this
person's spine being possessed right now
i just could figure out the room like
why are there numbers at the top of the
like that's some weird decor that's what
i mean it looks like an x-ray but this
uh yeah that could just be a rat right i
i see it as a rat
why is it like thermal cam these are
like thermal cameras in peru
i don't know it's like overly lit is
that what's going on here
i mean they have to be thermal because
the the thing is going under the chair
looks like
and then it's still picking up its body
heat right
yeah no i don't know what am i not
making sense am i at least smelling a
little smart
it looks like it's just kind of a shadow
or like a bubble of
something although there's different
places where i see a face like i see a
face
if you rewind it okay that looks like a
face like
see do you see like there's a nose and a
mouth and a chin and eyes
and then that thing goes over there it's
a rat but then if you look
looks like a snake no no that's gonna be
like a rat uh-huh
i don't know it's we're not gonna get
anywhere with this
we're just making our own predictions
all right yeah i thought this video was
uh another good delivery on nukes top
fives i don't know what we learned
but we learned something we grew as
people today
i don't know about editing yeah that's
what i may take away today thanks you
cat
thanks you cat for uh thanks to cat
three times the charm for being here
subscribe to real rejects click that
notification bell thanks a new top five
put together an awesome video hey check
out
cats villain of history history that's
right
villains of history podcasts villains of
history podcast
forgive me cat not much sleep we'll go
really early went on a run
i'm a little out of it okay and i warned
you before we filmed them a little out
and hey picture of the day shot oh wait
your fundraiser october 3rd yeah i have
a fundraiser it's october 3rd it's 12
hours of
12 hours 12 hours of comedy
from really intelligent people back to
back-to-back
shows of comedy you can access it by
donating 12
to the biden campaign by going to the
link below it's called laugh across
america
do it
speaking of scary daniel gallagher he's
embarking on the scariest of journeys
a he finally got his own car that is a
terrifying prospect you do not want a
scottish man behind the wheels trying to
take care and help out his family
driving they're all over the road
touching their crotch underneath their
kilts
bunch of perverts and daniel gallagher
is no exception
secondly he's thinking of starting up
his own reaction channel
man i'm telling you it's a scary
prospect
everything is demonetized nobody likes
what you do and then the people who like
what you do
are very demanding it's impossible to
win
daniel you should be afraid very
afraid speaking of driving i feel like
you'll drive your channel
way into the upward hill
because i take it all back having a
reaction channel was
great i'm so excited you're driving and
i
feel like you got the skills and
commentary
talent to pull it off daniel why don't
you come on drive out here and review
some
some things with us drive across the
atlantic ocean and we'll
hang out we'll do some reactions
together show you the ropes
love you daniel be safe daniel bring us
some scottish drugs don't die
[Music]